in the early 1990s California tax
authorities traveled to Las Vegas in
pursuit of businessman Gilbert Highet
they staked out his home dug through his
trash and hired a private eye to look
into his past they were after a piece of
his fortune never make a deal with an
extortionist they don't view themselves
as public servants they view themselves
as bounty hunters it's a story of greed
harassment anti-semitism and the abuse
of power this isn't the first time the
tax agency has strong-armed a citizen
but what's so unusual about Gilbert
Highet is that he fought back I've
waited 20 years for this
[Music]
Gilbert Highet made his fortune as the
patent holder of the microcomputer a
predecessor of the microprocessor Hyatt
was a resident of Orange County
California but in 1991 he packed up and
relocated to Las Vegas the following
year he was contacted by the California
Franchise Tax Board but I didn't realize
that it was going to be trouble because
I had moved I had sold my house I had I
was living in an apartment and then I
bought a house in Las Vegas and I was
very well settled an agent at the
Franchise Tax Board had read an article
about the potential billions of dollars
in royalties pouring in as electronics
companies like Philips and Sony started
licensing highest technology he decided
to investigate the tax agents concluded
that his move was a sham and that he
owed them more than 13 million dollars
in taxes fees and interest penalties
they would not agree that I became a
Nevada resident until I moved into my
house which was essentially the absurd
position that you have to buy a house
and move into it in order to change
residence which is not the law some
companies had already said goodbye to
Celt 154 companies of all sizes many of
them are simply moving out of California
it will move its national headquarters
jobs to the Lone Star State after Ella
for Nia's marginal income tax rates are
the nation's highest which drives many
wealthy residents to pack up and leave
Hyatt says he moved to Las Vegas because
casino billionaire Sheldon Adelson who
had dreams of creating a Silicon Valley
in Sin City lured him there no matter
the reason California didn't want to let
him go it's mostly the attitude of many
of the bureaucrats in the Franchise Tax
Board they don't view themselves as
public servants they view themselves as
bounty hunters and going out and getting
as much tax dollars as possible
John Coupole is the head of the Howard
Jarvis Taxpayers Association in
California he says that California's tax
agency is one of the most aggressive in
the nation California is often desperate
for revenue to cover its out-of-control
spending in 1993 when tax agents began
auditing Hyatt California faced a budget
deficit of 3.8 billion dollars the
largest in the nation the Franchise Tax
Board itself faced huge cuts and even
possible elimination
there are many systemic problems with
the inability to process tax returns
quickly their abusive investigatory
tactics Gill high it was an example of
this the agency can do whatever they
want and they have the staff and the
experience to do so today our judge jury
and executioner
shortly after the Tax Board opened its
audit an agent called hi it's lawyers
and advised him that most people just
settle because of wealthy or well-known
taxpayers do not want to risk having
their personal financial information
made public the Franchise Tax Board
believed that I was paranoid about my
privacy because I was a pro very private
person I worked very hard to keep my
address private because I had my lip
research lab there and therefore went
out of their way to breach my privacy in
order to intimidate me
hyatt declined to settle and appealed
the tax agency hired a private eye to
interview hi it's former California
neighbors 22 of whom later testified
that he did indeed move away after
selling his house they also sent letters
to his friends former colleagues and
even his rabbi I was shocked by those
letters that they were sending out for
several reasons first of all you look at
it and it looks like a criminal
investigation second of all it tells all
of my personal relationships businesses
entities friends my rabbis that I'm in
trouble with the Franchise Tax Board and
third of all it had my social security
number on it which is supposed to be
private to agents road trip to Las Vegas
staked out hi its new house rifled
through his trash and even took what a
whistleblower later described as a
trophy photo of his home the same
whistleblower testified that her
colleague and agent named Sheila Cox
vowed to get that Jew bastard
I was horrified when I learned that she
was a racist who had targeted me for my
religion hyatt ended up fighting a 25
year court battle spending more than ten
million dollars the state of California
spent more than twenty five million
dollars in the fight
according to the tax agency spokesman it
all came down to a hearing before the
Board of Equalization this August
although he has a professional legal
team hiyya decided to speak for himself
I've waited 20 years for this the board
ruled in Hyatts favor though it did
conclude that he continued to operate
portions of his business out of
California during the disputed six-month
period for this he was ordered to pay
1.9 million dollars out of the
approximately 55 million the tax agency
claimed he owed in taxes interest and
penalties and the board confirmed that
he was indeed a Nevada resident during
this time Hyatt also sued the Franchise
Tax Board for fraud and harassment and a
Nevada jury awarded him a 388 million
dollar judgment that was ultimately
reduced to $50,000 because of a
statutory cap on the amount state
agencies can be held liable for their
conduct somebody has got to stand up
against them power will corrupt and as
the cliche is the power to tax it's a
power to destroy
[Music]
you